à
et je suis très heureux de vous
retrouver pour le journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus si vous nous
rejoignez sur france 24 voici nos titres
ce soir à la hune transports publics à
l'arrêt bureau de poste fermés la
tunisie est paralysé par une grève menée
par la puissance du gtt les manifestants
protestent notamment contre la hausse
des prix et l'échec des négociations
salariales à la une également le
président de la transition burkinabé en
visite dans le village martyre de sainte
anne il ya le lieutenant-colonel dany
bahar a exprimé son soutien aux rescapés
le bilan de l'attaqué jihadiste a lui
été revu à la hausse il est désormais de
86 morts et puis nous irons en fin de
journal au congo brazzaville à la
découverte d'une application elle a été
créée pour dénoncer les abus des droits
de l'homme un projet vous le verrez pour
lutter contre l'impunité notre reportage
enfin deux journal
voilà donc pour les titres soyez les
bienvenus sur notre antenne la tunisie
est donc à l'arrêt ce jeudi une grève
dans le secteur public largement suivi
d'après le principal syndicat de
travailleurs luge et était face à
l'inflation ils réclament des mesures
pour un meilleur pouvoir d'achat une
grève alors que vous le savez le
président kaïs ayed qui s'est arrogé
quasiment les pleins pouvoirs l'an
dernier est sous le feu des critiques de
l'opposition une opposition exclus du
dialogue national censé aboutir à une
nouvelle constitution tanguy tricoit
avec les images de nos correspondants à
tunis
les aéroport désert des transports
publics à l'arrêt et des bureaux de
poste fermés en tunisie c'est tout le
secteur public qui était paralysé ce
jeudi suite à l'appel à la grève de luge
et était le principal syndicat du pays
nous sommes là pour protester contre la
dégradation du pouvoir d'achat après les
augmentations inédite est catastrophique
des prix et l'effet de l'inflation
ils étaient 3 millions à être appelés à
faire grève bloquant 1 659 entreprises
dans le pays
choyant malintrat pas devoir tout mais
la grève d'aujourd'hui arrive trop tard
mais c'est mieux que rien mais fon demi
avant je n'étais pas à 100 300 sont les
grèves
telle que nous la connaissons
aujourd'hui on constate une augmentation
des prix innovation on attend maintenant
selon moi le but de la grève n'est pas
social ni pour l'amélioration de la
situation du citoyen tunisien le but est
politique et c'est peut-être une réponse
à l'idée du référendum du président de
la république
l'union générale tunisienne du travail
protester également contre un projet de
réforme du secteur public qui a été
menée selon eux sans leurs consultations
nous avons des accords avec le
gouvernement ces accords là ne sont pas
appliquées j'espère que nos partenaires
c'est ce message là les verts la
négociation sociale et se mettre à table
pour trouver les solutions qui seront
acceptables par tous et partout plus que
jamais la pression monte sur le
président queille cède lui qui a
pourtant besoin du soutien de l'ue gtt
pour son projet de réforme présenté au
fonds monétaire international dans
l'espoir d'obtenir un nouveau prêt pour
le pays
[Musique]
la tunisie un pays au bord de l'asphyxié
financière elle demande une aide de 4
milliards de dollars au fmi en échange
le gouvernement doit mettre en place de
profondes réformes le point justement
sur la situation économique tunisienne
c'est avec julie à gougenheim en images
en tunisie les prix augmentent tous les
jours l'inflation atteint 7 % en moyenne
depuis le début de l'année le prix de
certains produits comme l'huile et les
oeufs a pris jusqu'à 25% la farine et la
semoule disparaissent elles
régulièrement des rayons en cause les
sécheresses à répétition qui menace les
récoltes et la guerre en ukraine d'où la
tunisie importe normalement 50% de
cibler les crises se succèdent
la chute du tourisme lié à la pandémie a
fait grimper le chômage à 18% la réponse
du gouvernement de l'époque en août 2020
un plan d'embauchés massives dans la
fonction publique qui a finalement été
annulée l'année dernière en effet les
caisses de l'état sont vides le pays est
endetté à 100% de son pib
le gouvernement a demandé une aide de 4
milliards de dollars au fmi en échange
de quoi il doit mener des réformes
structurelles
dans le viseur du fonds monétaire
international la réduction de la masse
salariale des 650 mille fonctionnaires
du pays autre sujet de négociation les
denrées alimentaires de base
subventionnés ces subventions coûtait
déjà deux milliards de dollars par an à
l'état tunisien soit 6%
avant même la guerre en ukraine
les réformes demandées par le fmi risque
de générer des crispations de plus en
plus forte au sein de la population et
d'accentuer les tensions politiques
le président kaïs sayyed est sous le feu
des critiques après s'être arrogé les
pleins pouvoir il ya onze mois il est
exclu l'opposition et plusieurs acteurs
de la société civile de la rédaction de
la nouvelle constitution qui sera
soumise à référendum ce 25 juillet
dans l'actualité du continent également
ce nouveau bilan au burkina faso la
taille 10 à 10 qui a frappé le village
de cette tenga le week-end dernier a
fait 86 morts plus de 8000 personnes se
sont ensuite réfugiés à dori la grande
ville nous allons toujours le président
de la transition le lieutenant-colonel
damiba il s'est lui rendu ce mercredi
sur place il a rencontré notamment des
rescapés écoutez comment ça
nous sommes venus
pour vous exprimer dans un premier temps
la douleur et puis notre compassion
à l'endroit des habitants de la localité
des sit in à ce qui s'est passé ici
c'est quelque chose d'inimaginable
pour des populations
désarmées
qui ne demandent qu'à vivre
nous allons tout faire pour les
retrouver
et la paix rhdp ce prix là à moi aussi
de l'armée togolaise qui dit avoir
repoussé une nouvelle attaque dans
l'extrême nord-ouest du togo à la
frontière justement avec le burkina faso
au cours des deux derniers mois deux
attaques terroristes ont justement
frappé cette zone les autorités ont
décrété lundi à l'état d'urgence
sécuritaire dans toute la région des
savanes elle est située dans le nord du
pays précision pour france 24 de notre
correspondante dans la région et j'ai
nommé emmanuel sol gis
aucun mort ni blessé selon le porte
parole de l'armée togolaise
actuellement la zone de l'attaqué
quadrillé par les forces armées mais en
fait cela fait bien longtemps que toute
cette zone du nord est sous haute
surveillance fin 2021 je m'étais moi
même rendu dans cette région et j'avais
constaté qu'il y avait déjà un fort
déploiement militaire
depuis novembre dernier c'est la
troisième fois le nord du togo est visée
par des attaques le mois dernier encore
un incident avait fait huit morts côté
forces de sécurité et 13 blessées et une
quinzaine de présumés jihadistes avaient
été tués selon le gouvernement du togo
l'attaqué avait eu lieu toujours dans
l'extrême nord mais cette fois ci
complètement à l'opposé à l'est jusqu'à
présent pas de revendications sur l'
attaque de la nuit dernière mais les
précédentes avaient été revendiqués par
le groupe de soutien à l'islam et aux
musulmans liés à al qaîda et comme vous
le savez le groupe les groupes
djihadistes qui sont implantées dans le
sahel souhaite progresser vers les côtes
du togo du bénin du ghana et la côte
d'ivoire et ces pays sont d'ailleurs
réunis au sein de l'initiative d'accra
met sur pied depuis cinq ans une
initiative qui est censé permettre
d'échanger des informations des
renseignements et préparer des
opérations militaires conjointes et la
cedeao étudie aussi actuellement des
pistes de collaboration avec l'otan sur
la question de la lutte contre le
terrorisme et de son côté début juin le
ministre togolais des affaires
étrangères avait sollicité l'appui
d'israël pour lutter contre le
terrorisme
lors de sa visite dans l'état hébreu et
enfin depuis trois jours sachez que les
autorités togolaises ont placé la zone
du grand nord la région des savanes en
état d'urgence sécuritaire
on en vient à présent à cette situation
toujours très tendue dans l'est de la
république démocratique du congo trois
jours après la prise de la ville
frontalière de bunagana par les rebelles
du m23 kinshasa accuse le rwanda de
soutenir la rébellion ce que kigali
dément le conseil supérieur de défense
demandent aujourd'hui au gouvernement
congolais de suspendre tous les accords
conclus avec kigali et ce jeudi martin
fayulu c'est un nom qu'on connaît bien
le candidat malheureux à la
présidentielle de 2010 8 il s'est
exprimé face à la presse il reproche
notamment au président tshisekedi ses
nombreuses promesses faites aux pays
voisins on va l'écouter tout de suite
venus qui ce qui est dit a signé avec
une légèreté déconcertante
des accords secrets avec les pays
voisins de l'est au détriment du congo
et de son peuple
il est allé jusqu'à souhaiter la
sécurité de notre pays au rwanda et à
l'ouganda particulièrement
l'invitation de la police rwandaise a
s'est déployée à goma rejeté par la
population avait une peur
la mutualisation des activités
militaires avec l'armée ougandaise sans
ces soucis et des conséquences que cela
pouvait avoir en équipement outre
il a aussi signé deux accords secrets
avec le rwanda qui trahissent sa
légèreté dans les engagements qu'il
prend propos recueillis par notre
correspondant clément bonne rôle les
atteintes aux droits de l'homme elles
sont nombreuses en république du congo
notamment les violences policières mais
les suspects sont rarement poursuivis
peu de victimes portent plainte
également et c'est justement pour
documenter ces abus qu une ong a lancé
une application mobile son but je vous
le donne en mille récolter un maximum de
témoignages c'est un reportage à
brazzaville de rosie piotte notre
correspondante
mariani comme à sanaa et un journaliste
spécialisé en questions
environnementales de retour du
département de la sangha où il a
constaté plusieurs violations des droits
humains ils utilisent l'application d'un
money pour les dénoncer quand je sors
département de la sangha précisément
dans la localité de delgo où j'ai
constaté en fait ici là nous avons qui
fait quoi donc la société de créer ici
on peut mettre le type de violations
qu'on a constatée et là c'est la date
chaque signalement attirer ici dans les
locaux des louanges et centres d'action
pour le développement à brazzaville
revis fait partie de l'équipe en charge
des les récents c'est une fois qu'un
utilisateur on voit la signalisation
nous recevons une notification au niveau
de notre base de données et après en
contact avec la personne qui a signalé
en passant par des questionnaires pour
en savoir un peu plus et c'est comme ça
que nous procédons
derrière cette application présent il à
l'un des principaux militants pour les
droits humains au congo selon lui trop
de violations et d'abus restent impunis
dans les pays car ils ne sont pas
dénoncés au regard de la flamme la
capacité des organisations des droits
humains mais aussi d'autres institutions
à couvrir
la situation des droits humains sur
l'ensemble du territoire no money est
une solution qui
qui est donné à
l'ensemble de la population pour faire d
alerte lorsqu'il y à des abus d'autorité
ou faire les alertes lorsque les droits
sont violés lancé les 2 mai dernier
l'application compte déjà une
soixantaine d'utilisateurs lohan
j'espère en faire un outil efficace pour
des enquêtes et obtenir justice pour les
victimes
l'ateq africaine elle est à l'honneur
ici à paris pour la première fois le
salon viva tech a lancé un prix spécial
pour les startups africaine trois
d'entre elles ont été récompensés dans
les catégories santé environnement et
finances c'est un reportage pour france
24 de christophe dans cet art mengo avec
landry taichung
cette égyptienne de 39 ans ambitionne de
créer le dr lib afrique à côté de son
métier de pédiatres rachat a monté sa
start up il ya quatre ans une
application qui permet de déposer une
ordonnance médicale et de recevoir ces
médicaments directement chez soi
l'ordonnancé transmise à la pharmacie la
plus proche grâce à la localisation gps
qui pourra accepter de préparer et de
livrer les médicaments pour les patients
sans qu'ils aient à se déplacer
et si la pharmacie n'a pas le médicament
en question l'ordonance sera
automatiquement transmises à la
pharmacie suivante et ainsi de suite
jusqu'à ce qu'une pharmacie accepte
prépare les livres les médicaments sans
encombre
autre secteur porteur pour les
entrepreneurs africains les startups
environnementale ce kényan a développé
une entreprise de collecte de déchets
électroniques des déchets qu'il revend
ensuite recyclés il y a de plus en plus
d'objets électroniques donc il y aura
une forte croissance de déchets il doit
y avoir une entreprise qui s'occupe de
ces déchets là parallèlement il y a
aussi une pénurie de métaux rares qui
sont pourtant présents dans ces objets
donc il faut changer les mentalités et
sortir d'un mode de pensée linéaire pour
trouver une seconde vie à ces objets
l'univers des start-up africaine a connu
une croissance fulgurante depuis locaux
vides 19 plus de 5 milliards de dollars
2 levé l'année dernière plus de deux
fois plus qu'en 2020 mais cela reste
vingt fois inférieur aux investissements
en europe
il y à vraiment des entrepreneurs très
intéressant mais aussi des accélérateurs
qui les aident à créer leur start up et
résoudre des défis importants que ce
soit en afrique francophone ou
anglophone en afrique du nord ou en
afrique du sud les gens arrivent avec
des innovations vraiment très
intéressante parfaitement taillé aux
besoins du continent
signe de cette vitalité cette année aviv
avec une centaine de start-up africaines
ont fait le déplacement à paris
sept pays tiennent un stand officiel
deux de plus que l'année dernière
voilà donc pour l'essentiel de
l'actualité du continent africain en ce
jeudi restez avec nous sur france 24
passé une très belle soirée